del presidente y del congreso de
Pantalones cortos republicanos Kevin MCC
amigo representante porcariforme tengo
usado
primera investigación contra el impuesto
de mi mayor Alvin
rompe un recital y le escribe un
tarjeta al Fiscal que saca una orgencia
en el congreso para reverenciar su esfuerzo
menores de sus investigaciones ed
discusiones Alex Presidente Donald Trump
precisamente el copresentador
agregalo ya Santos El con resista
que en Tauro en el currículum vitae de
actuar en el congreso por la razón e
h controversia y el Washington incluido en el
propia fiesta de lotería Zeppelin La
siento y el congreso aunque por parte Los y
representante que
es el presidente Trump y luego va a detener
todas las indicaciones para defenderte en
esecusio y que acusamos esto
precisamente entre eso y en uno
La persona también está encima de ella.
representatividad variada democracia
Leonardo diciendo que es una estimación que
un ex presidente debe tener cuidado de no pasar por alto
una acusación con